autre procès aujourd'hui celui qui
oppose le magazine valeurs actuelles à
danièle obono foule hebdomadaire est
jugée après la publication d'un article
de politique fiction en août dernier la
députée
la france est soumise ils étaient
représentés en esclaves sont ils
relèvent danièle obono s'est présenté
devant les devant le palais de justice
de paris soutenu par de nombreux élus et
député du mouvement dirigé par jean luc
mélenchon comme adrien 80 ans ou encore
mathilde de panneaux aujourd'hui se joue
quelque chose d'important pour moi
personnellement intimement
mais je crois aussi pour nous tous et
toutes on vit en ce moment dans un
contexte qui n'a fait que s'aggraver en
fait depuis depuis août dernier
depuis que beaucoup s'étaient exprimés
en étant choqué par les propos les
images qui me liait qui jouait de tous
les ressorts des delà des fantasmes et
de l'imagerie raciste et xénophobe